want to show you growth and i want to
show you what happened to borrowing as
well we've got new growth numbers from
the office for budget responsibility
this is the big picture really this is
you know how well is the economy doing
and whether these bars are kind of above
the line or below the line and that
shows the economy is growing nothing
above the line that shows the economy is
shrinking and obviously you'll see
that's what happened during the pandemic
an enormous fall these are the last
figures i should say so the last time
the obr looked at these numbers earlier
on this year this is how these bars look
well let me update them with the latest
numbers we just had through today and
you can see there is a change isn't
there just look this year i was saying
earlier we need to have a look at this
particular year so 2021 and what
happened to this bar did it go up and
yes it has gone up from four percent to
6.5 percent so a very big upgrade there
that is a big
upgrade and one of the strongest years
that we've seen for economic growth
basically in the last few decades
however then you've got a bit of a cut
in the 2022 basically the bounces has a
different profile doesn't it when you're
looking at what's happening to the
economy it's called a slightly different
profile slightly stronger this year
slightly weaker the next year and then
have a look through here we go down go
into the future so we're moving through
to 25 26
and here's the other thing that's
striking okay these numbers 1.6 percent
that is not
really punchy long-term economic growth
we're talking about you know below what
used to be considered trend growth of
about two and a half percent so
is that a bit of a disappointment
perhaps economists will look at that and
say well if you're hoping for a big
productivity busting budget putting
money into leveling up and hoping for
you know an improvement in our long-term
growth potential that's not all that
encouraging at 1.6 percent that's the
official forecast from the obr just
through just now and let's have a look
to borrowing so obviously if you've got
stronger growth that means potentially
more tax revenues coming in and the
economy doing a little bit better as a
result and
certainly the public finance has really
needed something like that this shows
you borrowing last time around so again
the forecast from the obr last time
around very big borrowing during the
pandemic obviously this is the year that
we're in at the moment let's see how
those have changed can we add the new
figures on so these are the latest
triggers from the obr which have cut the
borrowing forecast in this year in the
next year in the year after that in the
year after that all the way through
over into the end of the forecast
horizon where you're talking about
really quite low levels of borrowing 46
billion 46 billion 44 billion that's
that's really small by the comparisons
of recent years you know by both the
pandemic and the post-financial crisis
years uh and obviously comes back to
that point that richly centered wanted
to make that it is about fiscal
responsibility you know you don't have
massive giveaways uh towards the end of
the forecast horizon raising a question
you know and this is a political
question which both of you will be more
qualified to talk about than i will but
at this point does the chancellor then
have more leeway even within his
self-imposed fiscal rules to start doing
tax cuts or indeed giveaways before a
potential election in either of those
two years it looks like but you know
this is a budget which could gear you up
for some giveaways in the future because
it wasn't enormous when it came to those
giveaways